the future we see it in movies we read
about it in novels we hear it in the
dogma of those who lead us the future is
really something that we all as human
beings think about especially when this
future may directly have an impact on us
be it for better or for worse
now the world wide web was the biggest
revolution of the last century and it
feels like we're at the cusp of this
century's revolution behold web 3
my name is bradley this is some sub and
together let's understand whether web 3
is the future of the internet or just a
scammy fairy tale
the world has changed
i feel it
in the blockchain
[Music]
much that once was
is now lost
[Music]
so what's going on well before we start
speaking about web 3 itself let's try to
understand
why there's a number 3 there in the
first place and what the previous
version of the internet actually looked
like now you might not remember it but a
long long time ago a project that was
funded by the united states department
of defense ended up expanding so much
that it formed what we now know as the
world wide web
i was there
i was there 3 000 years
[Music]
so let's talk about web one
back in the pre-facebook era just a few
individuals knew how to navigate and
utilize the internet the internet was
very static meaning that the information
contained in it didn't really change
that much at all
no
pull to refresh on your instagram feed
you know
and back then people waited for emails
without getting notifications
there was just no technology that could
make that happen moreover where would
these notifications have been displayed
in the first place on a pager what
hustling was like in the 90s
hey yo what's up you paged me
and making content wasn't as
straightforward a task as it is now
the flow of information was also one way
in web one
webmasters decided what material to put
on their sites which would then later be
seen or downloaded by the end users the
webmaster had complete control over the
material in that structure while the end
user had none at all the internet was
kind of like a library with many books
all read-only and static and yes you
couldn't make notes in any of these
books
this dark ages of web 1.0 bought us for
example google that turned out to be the
biggest librarian in the library
and back then it wasn't a renowned
critic deciding on what's good and
what's bad
back in the day the internet was also
pricey since it charged users based on
the number of pages they viewed but with
both pcs and internet connection getting
cheaper the internet started slowly
transforming and became
web 2.
[Music]
by the way it's not like the evolution
of say a pokemon you know there's no
definite step that you can put your
finger on when it turned into web 2 from
web 1. web 2 is just jargon that
describes the changes and how people
interacted with the web indeed changes
that ended up differentiating it from
the traditional vintage internet
now web 2 is the current version of the
internet that we know and love both the
increased bandwidth and the advance of
technologies hardware and software
results in the creation of things such
as myspace facebook twitter tick tock
etc these sites and platforms gave users
a blank canvas on which they might look
to customize their experience and post
material for other people to see one
important element here is blogging which
has made the process of broadcasting
online so much easier for the general
public in 2006 time magazine put
everybody on the cover and that was
revolutionizing evolution people started
to view the internet differently it
became an integral part of everyday life
and the internet well it changed
accordingly websites became prettier and
easier to use while the technology that
makes it all work became much much more
sophisticated
for example one thing that was unheard
of in the web one era is online apps
things like google docs an office suite
that you don't actually have to install
on your pc with more content and code
hidden underneath web pages they're all
getting larger and larger and according
to the http archive this trend continues
even now day after day some experts
actually think that one of the key
differences between the web before and
the web now is gamification all of those
likes shares comments and other
interactions make our stone age brain
feel better about itself i remember back
in the day when i first got instagram i
couldn't stop refreshing my feed waiting
for my next like but what about you are
you still hooked on that dopamine binge
boat how much do likes mean to you let
me know in the comments web one was just
smaller it felt like a small town filled
with scientists journalists and other
experts right now well feels like i'm
back at secondary school especially when
it comes to twitter in web 2 the rate
with which information is created
accelerates constantly recent data from
domo shows that over 65 000 photos that
are uploaded to instagram every single
minute and as of july 2021 the internet
reaches 65 of the world's population and
thus connects 5.17 billion people and
that number was just 2 billion 10 years
ago
because of the pure volume of the data
generated web 2 started to rely on
suggestion algorithms more and more and
as we've discussed many times on this
channel it all usually comes at a price
[Music]
web 2 is dominated by big tech companies
that's no secret
they provide their services for free
but really in exchange for personal data
acting as a proxy providing use to user
communication it really acts as a
trustworthy middleman between two
individuals who do not know or trust one
another it also establishes all
transaction rules and maintains control
over all user data
people have little control over the data
and usually exchange their privacy for
convenience
the client sends or retrieves data from
a server that's centrally stored and
also maintained
our information is given to a service
provider with every online contact as a
result we lost control of our data long
ago for example
are your photos on instagram really
yours
[Music]
well based on the latest update of
instagram's terms of use it has been
stated that
we do not claim ownership of your
content but you grant us a license to
use it
now listen
you hereby grant us to a non-exclusive
royalty-free transferable sub-licensable
worldwide license to host
use distribute modify
run copy publicly perform or display
translate and create derivative works of
your content you own your photos but we
may use them how we want effectively not
the best conditions to share your photos
on right
moreover let's not forget that google
and facebook make the vast majority of
their revenue from advertisements based
on user information advertising today
gets in your way pop-up ads unskippable
video ads these things that block the
flow
is counter-intuitive to the idea of
having a memorable and pleasurable
experience online furthermore our data
is kept on a cloud that's freely
accessible posing a trust concern if
it's not verified properly
do you have faith in the centralized
entities that are in charge of your data
these problems of web to worried
intellectuals all around the world for
more than a decade and it looks like
they've already found a solution that
would bring the control back to us
the users
what is web3 well it's an idea for a new
version of the world wide web that uses
state-of-the-art technologies to provide
decentralization the term web 3 was
actually coined by ethereum's co-founder
gavin wood in 2014
and that's probably the reason why so
much of web3 based concepts rely on
technologies that are connected to
cryptocurrencies for example blockchains
which are distributed digital ledgers
now web3 is not to be confused with tim
berners-lee's version for a semantic web
often known as web 3.0 that he actually
formulated back in 1999. now the
semantic web's purpose was to make all
data on the internet machine readable
and we'll probably talk about that in
one of our later videos but for right
now let's agree to use the term web 3.
specific versions of web3 tend to differ
and because of that the concept itself
is actually quite hard to grasp even
bloomberg called it hazy now in an
article they described web3 as an idea
that would build financial assets in the
form of tokens into the inner workings
of almost anything that you do online
well thank you bloomberg but isn't that
also too hazy of a definition after
synthesizing all of the data from web 2
i think i can boil it down to the
following metaphor let's imagine that
web one was like a small park in your
neighborhood that's run by your local
government not much gets done there's
not much great stuff to do there but
thank god there is one and it's clean
web 2 is like the people that organize
games and other activities in that very
park they can do only what's allowed by
the local government and nothing more
and also in this version some companies
may fund tennis courts to be placed in
the park or say plant trees
web 3 is like a forest it's like mother
nature
there are obviously certain rules that
everyone should obey to keep the forest
safe and pretty but most importantly
nobody owns the forest and everyone is
allowed to use it
moreover there's no central control and
mother nature makes sure that the forest
heals itself in case of a disaster for
instance indeed the main feature of such
a system is decentralization and here is
the point from which everybody sees web
3 differently developers say it's more
about technical aspects and say back-end
programming but others see it as almost
an anarchist vision of the future for
example one of the visions of web 3
incorporates the idea of decentralized
autonomous organization as explained by
ethereum.org
think of them like an internet native
business that's collectively owned and
managed by its members they have built
in treasuries that no one has the
authority to access without the approval
of the group decisions are governed by
proposals and voting to ensure that
everyone in the organization has a voice
you know i remember somebody expressing
similar ideas distributing is just as
fine as sharing it
another concept that's thrown around a
lot when talking about web3 is
decentralized finance or d5 now it uses
smart contracts which are simply
programs stored on a blockchain that run
when pre-determined conditions are met
for example buying milk when there is
zero of it in fridge now these
essentially enable financial instruments
to be created without relying on
intermediaries everything's just a
simple set of small programs
and sure crypto countries are also an
essential part of that and we know that
already at least 13 percent of americans
traded crypto in 2021. if you're tech
savvy though you may already be aware
that such things already exist in the
present version of the internet and
you're correct some of the features of
the next-gen internet are now being
implemented into the services that we
use every single day blockchain
technology is spreading throughout many
apps and sites like paypal microsoft
amazon and others but it's not really
web 3 yet in its complete version web3
would allow sites and services to exist
across decentralized computer networks
and rely on blockchain technology to
validate user data
the people who actually use sites and
apps would then theoretically own them
participate in an online community
enough and you'd get social credit
sorry i meant a piece of it in the form
of a digital token consumers rather than
large corporations would govern the
service itself creators would get more
money for views and there'd be no real
centralized censorship
people would vote on the rules of the
platform and there would be no private
data leaks either the people would
decide what algorithms do instead of
vice versa
the war against machines and big tech
would be over now this is what a big
dream looks like but what about real
life implementations
and why do so many tech savvy people
like elon musk think that web 3 is all
hype and zero reality metaverse
situation um or
web 3 sounds like more marketing than
reality
i don't get it
[Music]
the rebranding of facebook is meta in
october of 2021 as well as the company's
increased support for cryptocurrencies
propelled web3 concepts like blockchain
and decentralized technology into the
mainstream
at a closer look it becomes pretty
obvious that most of what web 3 is now
it's just old technologies and concepts
in new hyped up packaging but hang on a
minute don't we all know a company that
does that every year
so why can't others
web 3 right now looks like something
that just combines all ideas about
blockchain d5 dao and others into a form
that may be consumed by wall street now
let's take a look at what professionals
are actually saying about this in the
industry take a look at this tweet from
former ceo of twitter jack dorsey
elon musk the ceo of tesla inc also
joined the conversation by asking
whether anybody had seen web 3 to which
dorsey answered it's somewhere between a
and z implying that it's under the
ownership of a16z
the venture capital company established
by mark anderson and ben harrowitz by
the way they're huge supporters of web 3
so there are no surprises there i bet
you as a user of the future web might
have a conflict of interests with those
venture capital funds when it comes to
your data big tech companies have
already invested in web3 do you expect
trillion dollar companies that make up
the larger internet ecosystem to give up
their control come on business
this is evolution
this is evolution of the human species
what are you doing bringing this you
know that bash has over 40 million data
points on you and every decision you
have made since 1994 doctor the fact of
the matter is that web 3 isn't some new
version of the internet to which we'll
have to migrate
it's a result of the present internet's
expansion
and it'll most likely be a smooth shift
that you won't even notice
after all no one can even name the exact
state that we switched from web 1 to web
2. can you if anything the massive
option of web 3 tech is only just
getting started only about 10 of the
world's population owns cryptocurrency
decentralized financial systems already
have roughly 100 billion in assets which
is still a small fraction of what the
traditional financial system has despite
the fact that web3 apps have tens of
millions of users they still pale in
contrast to the billions that utilize
web 2 applications if anything i think
it's important to consider where the
money's going
investment in cryptocurrencies and
blockchain companies has increased
dramatically lately
do you like money
well what if i told you there was a way
to exchange those boring green
presidential napkins for sexy computer
cash while the market is breaking one
record after the other some experts
including nassim talib and warren
buffett have a skeptical view that the
rising price of cryptocurrencies
constitutes a speculative bubble and as
long as cryptocurrencies are an
essential part of the internet if those
experts are right the web v3 could
become a dot-com bubble v2 destroying
most of the investment that's been
pumped into it but you know maybe it
will be for the better by rebooting the
current state of affairs in any case
skeptics could be wrong maybe it's just
the beginning of a great future for all
of us and web 3 would become frodo
baggins in this story in the end
privacy is your only true precious that
many golems of the world would like to
take from you and use it at their will
but let's hope that that group of brave
hobbits would eventually destroy the
ring and the eye of mordor would finally
fall it's watching over all of us
[Music]
well anyway thanks for joining me on
another rampant some rambunctious rain
dance around the rosy red radioactive
core of the online jungle i will see you
all in the next video thanks for joining
us
[Music]
you